بعد موجه احتجاجات وفوضى داخل اسرائيل
نتنياهو يبحث اليوم تعليق تعديلات القضاء
البيت الابيض يعرب عن قلقه الشديد من
التطورات في اسرائيل ويدعو الى ايجاد
تسويه باسرع وقت
وفي جلسه صاخبه البرلمان العراقي مرر
تعديل قانون انتخابات مجلس النواب ومجلس
المحافظات
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا
الى هذه النشره المفصله تاتيكم من العربيه
نبداها من التطورات المتسارعه التي تشهدها
اسرائيل حيث اعلنت نقابه العمال العامه
الاسرائيليه ستصدر قرارها اليوم بشان
اعلان اضراب عام يشمل مختلف المرافق فيما
دعى رئيس الحكومه بنيامينه قاده احزاب
الائتلاف الحاكم الى اجتماع طارئ صباح
اليوم وافاد تصريحات مسؤولين في حزب
الايكود لوسائل اعلام محليه قولهم انه يتم
النظر في امكانيه وقف التشريعات وان رئيس
الحكومه بني امينه نياهو قد يعلق قرار
تعديلات القضائيه على وقع الاحتجاجات
الشعبيه المستمره وافادت قناته او القناه
الثانيه عشره الاسرائيليه بان رئيس
الحكومه نتنياهو وزعيم حزب شاص يؤيدان وقف
التعديلات القضائيه فيما يعارضها كل من
وزيره الامن القومي والعدل الذي هدد
بالاستقاله اذا تراجع نتنياه و عن
التعديلات القضائيه واكد وزراء ونواب من
حزب الليكود انهم ملتزمون بتاييد نتنياهو
اذا اخذ قرارا بتعليق هذه التعديلات
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هذا هو يدرس وزير الدفاع الاسرائيليه
المقالانت تقديم التماس للمحكمه العليا
الاسرائيليه ضد قرار اقالته الذي اصدره
رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو ووفقا لما
افادت به القناه الثانيه عشره العبريه فان
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي المقال تواصل مع
احد اكبر مكاتب المحاماه لتحقق من خياراته
القانونيه ضد قرار اقالته
هذا وقد افاد افادت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه
بان القنصل العام الاسرائيلي في نيويورك
اساس زمير قدم استقالته بعد اقاله وزير
الدفاع
وقال القنصل اساف زمير في تغريده على
تويتر ان الوضع في اسرائيل وصل الى لحظه
حرجه وانه يشعر بمسؤوليه عميقه والتزام
اخلاقي للنضال من اجل القيم الديمقراطيه
واضاف قائلا ان قرار اليوم الخطير باقاله
وزير الدفاع اقنعه بانه لم يعد يستطيع او
لم يعد يستطيع تمثيل هذه الحكومه
وفي اول ردود على ما يجري في اسرائيل اعرب
البيت الابيض عن قلقه اذا التطورات بعد
اقاله وزير الدفاع وافكالانت من منصبه
بسبب رفضه التعديلات القضائيه وقال البيت
الابيض في بيان انما يجري في اسرائيل
سيؤثر على امنها وجيشها
اما المتحدثه باسم مجلس الامن او المتحدث
باسم المجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
فقالت في بيان ان الولايات المتحده تشعر
بقلق عميق ازاءه ما يحدث او ما يجري في
اسرائيل وتحث ايضا القاده الاسرائيليين
بقوه على ايجاد حل وسط في اقرب وقت ممكن
اضاف البيانات ان الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن ناقش مؤخرا مع رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي
مؤكدا على ان دعم الولايات المتحده لامن
اسرائيل وديمقراطيتها لا يزال صارما
استكمل مجلس نواب العراقيه تصويت على
التعديل الثالث لقانون انتخابات مجالس
المحافظات في جلسه حضرها 189 نائبا ووصى
اجواء مشحونه تحت قبه البرلمان صوت مجلس
النواب على تعديل الماده السادسه من
القانون وصوت البرلمان العراقي على اعتماد
صيغه تمثيل انتخابي وفق نظام
والذي اعتبره معرضون عراقيون قانونا تم
تفصيله على مقاس القوى المتنفذه في البلاد
ويعيد نظام دائره الواحده الذي كان معمولا
به في الماضي
اسمع اسمع
الامن
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
تلقى وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان اتصالا هاتفيا من وزير خارجيه
ايران حسين امير عبد الله وقد جرى خلال
الاتصال مناقشه عدد من الموضوعات المشتركه
في ضوء الاتفاق الثلاثي الذي تم توقيع
عليه في الصين كما اتفق وزير الخارجيه
السعودي ونظيره الايراني على عقد لقاء
ثنائي خلال شهر رمضان
قال قصر العزي في بيان ان الرئيس الفرنسي
والمكان اجرى اتصالا هاتفيا بولي العهد
السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
واناقشاه سبلت عزيزي التعاون بين البلدين
خصوصا في مجالي الطاقه والدفاع كما ناقشا
عددا من قضايا او القضايا الاقليميه
والعالميه
سلمت اللجنه الفنيه المكلفه بصيغه الاتفاق
النهائي في السودان والمكونه من 11 عضوا
من القوى المدنيه الواقعه على الاتفاق
الايطالي وممثل لكل من القوات المسلحه
السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع سلمت
المسوده الاوليه للاتفاق للاطراف المدنيه
والعسكريه المنخرطه في العمليه السياسيه
بصوره رسميه وذلك بحضور رئيس مجلس السياده
الانتقاليه الفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان
تاتي هذه الورشه في وقت دقيق تمر به
بلادنا
ووسط تحديات مجمع تتهدد سيادتها وتماسكها
واستقرارها ومخاطر تحيط بها من كل جانب
ويتضم هذه الورشه المئات من العسكريين
والمدنيين فانهم يجتمعون قبل كل شيء
كسودانيين مهمومين بمستقبل بلادهم يوحدهم
حب هذا الوطن وحرصه البالغ على حمايته
واصرارهم على وضعه في موقعه الامثل الذي
يليق به
وبشعبه العظيم وموارده الهائله وموقعه
الجغرافيه الفريد
تزايد دا نشاط الارهابي في افريقيا ادى
الى تصعيد عمليه السلطات ضمن ضد التنظيمات
المتطرفه كتنظيم داعش الذي يتسع نفوذه على
حساب تنظيم القاعده
حرب اعلنتها نيجيريا على التنظيمات
الارهابيه كانت اخر نتائجها قتل اعداد من
عناصر بوكو حرام وعمليه ادت الى مقتل قائد
تنظيم داعش في المنطقه
نشاط متصاعد للسلطات الافريقيه ناجم عن
اتساع رقعه نفوذ تلك التنظيمات المتطرفه
في القاره السمراء خصوصا تنظيم داعش فقد
افادت احصائيات اجرتها المراكز الدوليه
المتخصصه منها معهد واشنطن للدراسات
والمركز الوطني لمكافحه الارهاب بان داعش
يتقدم بنفوذه على حساب القاعده لينتشر
بشكل كبير في منطقه الساحل الافريقي خصوصا
مالي وتشد ويتحرك نحو نيجيريا بحسب
تقديرات مؤشر الارهاب العالمي كما استطاع
انتزاع ولاء بعض الجماعات المتطرفه
المرتبطه بالقاعده في المنطقه
وتيره الهجمات الارهابيه تصاعدت على مدى
الاشهر الماضيه من اعتداءات وتفجيرات
وعمليات ليس فقط بين المدنيين بل بين داعش
والقاعده وكل من يتماشى مع فكرهما خصوصا
مع اندثار التنظيمين من منطقه الشرق
الاوسط
فوضى وعجز في السلطه وهشاشه في الاوضاع
السياسيه والامنيه كلها عوامل ادت الى
توسع نفوذ الجماعات المتطرفه في القاره
السمراء ورغم التراجع النسبي في ضحايا
الارهاب الا ان التحذيرات الامنيه تشير
الى عدم الاستهانه بداعش تحديدا خاصه بعد
سحب فرنسا قواتها العسكريه من القاره
لصالح روسيا اذا عمر العربيه
نشرتنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد قليل
الاف بي اي يؤكد للجنه المخابرات في مجلس
الشيوخ جاهزيته للتعامل مع اي عنف مرتبط
بقضيه ترامب
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت الخارجيه
الليتوانيه ان ليتوانيا تدعو لعرض عقوبه
جديده ردا على خطه روسيا لنشر اسلحه نوويه
تكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا واقلت الخارجيه في
بيانها انها ستقرر مع شركائها في اوروبا
كيفيه الرد على تلك الخطه وستدعو لتبني
عقوبات جديده
تواصل روسيا انتاج طرق غير نظاميه بشن
بشحن نفطها عبر وجهات مختلفه عبر ناقلات
يتجاوز عمرها 15 عاما تفتقر للصيانه
والمتابعه حيث كشف تقرير صادر عن صحيفه دي
ايكونومي تايمز بان استمرار موسكو
باستخدام هذا النوع من الناقلات النفطيه
قد يتسبب في اخطار بيئيه كبيره
طريق ملتفه تعتمدها موسكو لنقل نفطها عبر
اسطول الظل الذي يضم اكثر من 100 ناقله
تفتقل لوثائق التامين على الشحن بسبب
العقوبات الغربيه نقلات نفطيه يتجاوز
عمرها 15 عاما منها الناقله توربا التي
تبحر تحت عالم الدوله ذات المكانه الضعيفه
للاشراف على السلامه البحريه وهي
الكاميرون وتقوم بنقل الملايين من براميل
النفط دون تامين مناسب حيث كشف تقرير صادر
عن صحيفه ذئبس بان استمرار موسكو باستخدام
هذا النوع من السفن القديمه التي لا يتم
فحصها وصيانتها بشكل صحيح ينطوي على اخطار
بيئيه كبيره قد تتسبب في اسوا تسربات
للنفط في التاريخ الاوروبي ما لا يقل عن
اربعين سفينه قديمه ابحرت لالاف الاميال
من ميناء سان بطرسبرجر الروسي وقامت بنقل
النف الى الصين والهند وتركيا بين اوائل
ديسمبر واوائل فبراير الماضي كما تقوم بعض
السفن بنقل حمولاتها الخطيره في اعالي
البحار في المياه الدوليه قباله اليونان
او معبر السبت الاسباني شمال افريقيا وهي
مخاطره ضخمه تهدد الملاحه البحريه
الاوروبيه والعالميه خصوصا وان ناقله
توربا فقط نقلت مؤخرا الاورال درجه الخامه
الروسيه الرئيسيه الى الهند واذا ابحرت
الى اسيا فستتضمن الابحار في بحر البلطيق
وعبور العديد من السواحل الاوروبيه رحله
الوقود الروسي وفق تقرير سابق لفايناشل
تايمز كانت تبدا من محطه تكرير تابعه
لعملاق النفط الروسي لوك اويل في جزيره
صقليه الايطاليه وهي التي سمحت لروسيا
بتحقيق مكاسب ماديه حتى بعد فرض العقوبات
اعلنت لجنه المخابرات من مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي ان مكتبه التحقيقات الفيدرالي اف
بي اي جاهز لاي عنف مرتبط بقضيه الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونت ترامب وكانت رام قد
سبق ان حذر من موت ودمار محتملين ان وجهه
او وجه اليه مدعي عاما هاتا اتهامات
جنائيه
هذا واينشغل الامريكيون من جديد بالحمله
الرئاسيه للرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
والذي عاد الى الاضواء والاعلام مجددا
عدد دولار ليشغل الحياه السياسيه
والاعلاميه في الولايات المتحده ونادرا ما
تنظر الى برنامج سياسي من دون ان يكون
الحديث حول دونالد ترامب وتشير اخر
استطلاعات الراي الى انه يتقدم على اقرب
منافسيه الجمهوريين حاكم فلوريدا
باكثر من عشر نقاط ويتقدم على الرئيس
الحالي جو بايدن في الانتخابات العامه
باربعين نقاط مئويه
السلاح الجديد الذي يستعمله الديمقراطيون
في الانتخابات وملاحقه مرشح بتهمه جنائيه
ويصنعون دعايه وهذا من مصلحتي فشعبيه صعدت
الى اعلى مستوى
واستغل محامي ترامب برامج الاحد السياسيه
ليقول ان مدعي عام نيويورك يعمل بتوجيه من
اداره بايدن التي تسعى لاحباط حمله ترامب
الرئاسيه وليشدد ايضا على ان الاموال التي
تم دفعها للممثله الاباحيه
هي اموال شخصيه وليست اموال الحمله
الانتخابيه
هذه اموال شخصيه وكيف ما نظرت الى المساله
فهي اموال شخصيه وليست اموال حمله
انتخابيه
ولو رات هيئه المحلفين او من بعدها
المحكمه في نيويورك ان الاموال هي بالفعل
اموال شخصيه لسقطت هذه القضيه القانونيه
برمتها وبقي فقط الضجيج الذي اثارته
والمخاوف التي تسببت بها ومنها ما اعتبره
الديمقراطيون دعوه من قبل ترامب لاستعمال
العنف في الشارع
كلنا يتذكر الرعب في السادس من يناير وما
تسبب به الرئيس حين ذاك دونالد ترامب
واليوم يقول الامر ذاته وقد قدمت الاف بي
ايجازا لي وهم مستعدون
صاحب اكبر قاعده شعبيه في صفوف الحزب
الجمهوري وهو يتقدم باشواط في حملته
الانتخابيه على كل منافسيه الحزبيين وربما
ايضا الرئيس الديمقراطي الحالي
في الغنم العربيه
اعلن الجيش الكوري الجنوبي انا كوريا
الشماليه اطلقت صاروخا واحدا على الاقل هو
الاحداث في سلسله من اختيارات الاسلحه
خلال الاسابيع الاخيره
لا تقتصر زياره مكه المكرمه على اداء
العمره بل تحظى رحله الزائر والمعتمر
بتجربه ثقافيه فريده حراء الثقافي احد
ابرز الوجهات التي تثري تجربه زوار عبر
معارض ومتاحف متعدده سلسله من الحرمين مع
الزميل سلطان السلمي
[موسيقى]
حي حراء الثقافي بمكه يعد معلما سياحيا
وثقافيا يرتبط بجبل وغار حراء حيث المكان
الذي بدا فيه نزول الوحي على رسول الله
ويحظى بمكانه في وجدان المسلمين
ومع دخول شهر رمضان
تزداد اعداد الزوار للتعرف على تاريخ
الغار عبر مصادر علميه موثوقه ووسائل عرض
ذكيه
وبلغات متعدده
هو احدى مستهدفات رؤيه المملكه 2030 واحدى
ثمار التعاون بين القطاع الحكومي والقطاع
الخاص هذا المكون الثقافي الذي ترون يتكون
من مكونات اساسيه معرض الوحي هذا المعرض
الذي يتم استعراض فيه قصص الوحي مع
الانبياء بدم من ادم عليه السلام حتى محمد
صلى الله عليه وسلم مرورا بالانبياء اولي
العزم عليهم السلام
يقع الحي الثقافي على مساحه تزيد عن 67
الف متر مربع ويسهم في اثراء التجربه
المعرفيه والثقافيه للزوار عبر مكوناته
المتنوعه ويضم المشروع مركز الزوار ومتحف
القران الكريم كذلك معرض الوحي وطريق
الصعود الى الغار المكان جمع بين الرساله
التوعويه والرساله ايضا الترفيهيه
السياحيه فكل من يزور هذا المكان بامكانه
ان يتحصل على المعلومات والمعارف التي
تكون من مصادر موثوقه اضافه الى ذلك اماكن
ترفيهيه له ولعائلته تحظى المواقع
الاسلاميه والتاريخيه في السعوديه
باهتمام ملحوظ من قبل الجهات المعنيه التي
تعمل على تطويرها لجعلها وجهه سياحيه
ومقصدا لزوار الداخل والخارج من مكه
المكرمه
سلطان السلمي العربيه
ختام هذه النشره الى العناوين
بعد موجه احتجاجات وفوضى داخل اسرائيل
نتنياهو يبحث اليوم تعليق تعديلات القضاء
البيت الابيض يعرب عن قلقه الشديد من
التطورات في اسرائيل ويدعو الى ايجاد
تسويه باسرع وقت
في جلسه صاخبه البرلمان العراقي يمرر
تعديل قانون انتخابات مجلس النواب ومجالس
المحافظات
دائما العربيه
[موسيقى]